stéphane caillet médecins infectiologues
au chru de strasbourg bonjour merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation alors
l'assemblée nationale a prolongé l'état
d'urgence jusqu'au 1er avril
qu'en pensez vous ce est obligatoire
pour lutter efficacement contre la
pandémie de covile 19 et ce sont des
mesures extrêmement violente extrêmement
violente à la fois pour les pour les
clients les usagers et puis pour les
professionnels les cafetiers et les
restaurateurs
il est de mon point de vue vraiment
dommage que l'on en soit arrivé là
je pense que l'on aurait pu s'arranger
pour éviter de prendre des mesures aussi
aussi drastiques que nous aurons dit les
cafetiers et les restaurateurs
ils nous ont dit dans un premier temps
qu'il avait fait tout ce qu'il fallait
pour que les mesures de prévention
mesures barrières et soit appliquée et
puis en même temps ils ont avoué que
c'était extrêmement difficile à faire
appliquer et qu'il devait se battre tous
les jours
il est vrai que quand on est dans un
café quand on est au restaurant le port
du masque est très mal commode parce
qu'on est obligé de l'enlever elle sans
cesse de le remettre
et ça se comprend bien je déplore que
l'on ne peut que l'on que l'on n'ait pas
essayé de mettre en place des visière
transparente en plexiglas il existe
aujourd'hui des visières qui s'appuie
non pas sur le menton mais sur le front
qui ne coûte pas très cher de l'ordre de
1 euro 50 2 euros et qui sont moins
efficaces que les masques mais qui sont
tout de même à mon avis d'une efficacité
suffisante et qui aurait pu limiter la
transmission dans les cafés dans le
restaurant et c'est dommage qu'on n'ait
pas essayé cela alors il faut
reconnaître une chose c'est que le virus
circule aujourd'hui essentiellement dans
la tranche d'âge des adultes jeunes
c'est-à-dire des 20 à 35 ans et c'est
précisément cette clientèle qui
fréquente les cafés et puis les
restaurants qui sont très
qui sont très occupés pendant les repas
de midi mais aussi le soir donc vraiment
c'est dommage alors actuellement il
existe on constate qu'il existe une
rupture de confiance entre la population
les usagers et le gouvernement parce que
la politique et la communication du
gouvernement en matière de kobe 19 a été
quand même une mature sinueuse avec des
incohérences des contradictions on l'a
dit une chose et puis une autre et ça
c'est vraiment une mesure qui s'ajoute
aux autres et qui a mis à mon avis un
peu le feu aux poudres
parce que on a tendance à mme
additionner les mesures les unes aux
autres sans se donner vraiment les
moyens de les faire appliquer et si tu
as mon avis très dommage je pense que
l'on aurait pu s'arranger pour éviter
d'en arriver à cette situation qui est
assez dramatique comme on l'a entendu
pour pour les professionnels
vous dites on aurait pu s'arranger vous
parler notamment du port de l'art du
masque visière mais est ce que c'est
c'est suffisant pour lutter contre la
propagation du virus on sait que les cas
de contamination se multiplient tous les
jours ils se multiplient mais parce que
il y as je pense une certaine saturation
de la part de la population quant au
port du masque on a imposé le port du
masque à l'extérieur alors que c'est une
mesure qui n'est pas pertinente
dès l'instant où on marche dans la rue
le peut et qu'on est seul ou que l'on
croise des gens le masque ne sert à rien
et finalement on a saturé les gens ils
sont ils sont un petit peu excédé de
devoir porter le masque tout le temps et
tant et si bien que lorsqu'il se
retrouve dans un café dans un restaurant
surtout comme celle soir ils n'ont
qu'une hâte c'est l'essai était
d'enlever le masque et à ce moment là
effectivement on a un eu de transmission
le virus va circuler
trop de masques que tu le masque
alors stéphane caillet le virus tue -
aujourd'hui qu'au cours du mois de mars
avril mai est-ce qu'on a raison
aujourd'hui d'avoir toujours aussi peur
de ceux commis de 19 est ce qu'il faut
rester vigilant il faut rester vigilant
mais il y à une crainte qui est
excessive
effectivement aujourd'hui la mortalité
très faible et on nous parle tout le
temps de l'indicateur arn c'est à dire
le résultat des tests qui consiste à
faire un éco bio nage dans le rhino
pharynx et à rechercher non pas de virus
un mail arn viral
ce test finalement il est trop sensible
il ya des faux positifs
il est beaucoup plus important de
s'intéresser aux personnes et qui sont
malades et les deux indicateurs qui à
mon avis sont les plus pertinents c'est
à dire le nombre quotidien de nouvelles
hospitalisations pour coville 19 et le
nombre quotidien de nouvelle admission
en réanimation
aujourd'hui ces deux indicateurs sont
relativement bas on en est entre un
sixième et un septième du niveau le plus
haut lors du pic de l'épidémie fin mars
début avril
donc il me semble exagéré de parler de
seconde vague
il ya une reprise de l'épidémie c'est
vrai mais n'est pas exponentielle comme
cela a parfois été dit elle et elle est
progressive et pour le moment la
situation reste sous contrôle
donc on affole je trouve trop les gens
il faut faire attention il ne faut pas
diminuer la vigilance le masque doit
être portée dans et à l'intérieur des
locaux lorsque on est en concentration
humaine c'est important mais il ne faut
pas exagérer
merci pour cet éclairage l'interview
elle touche à sa fin je rappelle que
vous êtes médecin infectiologue au chru
de
je vous remercie beaucoup merci